[Musique]
il ya de plus en plus de signalements
mais on a dans les yvelines la chance
d'avoir
une autorité judiciaire qui répond plus
vite et plus fermement
[Musique]
le traitement judiciaire on n'oublie
jamais le principe d'individualisation
de l'examen de la situation au delà de
l'individualisation des peines et que
donc dans toutes les décisions
comprennent elles soient adaptés en fait
nous pouvons orienter les affaires vers
le tribunal pour poursuite on va dire
traditionnel est utilisée aussi tout le
domaine très très large des alternatives
aux poursuites qui constitue une
véritable prise en charge des victimes
dans un contexte différent
[Musique]
les alternatives aux poursuites
permettent notamment dans le cadre d'une
composition pénale de
d'accorder à une victime un téléphone
grand danger le téléphone grand danger
est à la main si je puis dire du parquet
et donc dans des cas où il faut agir
très rapidement dans le cas d'une
alternative aux poursuites on peut
mettre en place une protection
immédiatement le bracelet anti
rapprochement est quelque chose qui
suppose l'intervention d'un magistrat
puisque c'est une décision qui est très
lourde en terme d'atteinte aux libertés
et donc ça se décale un petit peu dans
le temps
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
on
constate dans les faits qui a de plus en
plus de ce qu'on appelle deux peines
mixtes c'est-à-dire une partie
d'emprisonnement ferme pour les faits
les plus graves avec un suivi derrière
ce qu'on appelle le sursis probatoire ce
sont des convocations régulières des
obligations à respecter et à justifier
et puis une vision donc une vigilance
particulière pour ces dossiers on a un
travail à faire aussi nous
en lien avec la justice et de développer
tout ce qui permet des stages tout ce
qui va permettre l'hébergement des
victimes et des auteurs séparément bien
sûr pour limiter là aussi la réitération
[Musique]